hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel wet today as a huge thanks
for hitting two hundred and fifty and
two hundred and sixty subscribers two
hundred and fifty and two hundred and
sixty thousand subscribers that's
correct in the last month I thought I
would do another Q&A I haven't done one
for like a year but people do request
them alot so here I am did get a couple
of questions so I'm gonna get through as
many as I can but if I didn't answer
yours I hope you understand Mitchell on
Instagram said do you miss anything from
not working at IGN anymore
oddly phrased I assume you're asking me
if I miss things from IGN and yeah I
miss the people I work with all the time
some of my best friends that I've ever
had in my whole life were in that
building I have so much fondness for
everyone there and obviously it's a way
bigger team than the team at fun house
so just a lot of people who I really
really care about and I miss them all
the time geumja I'm just called Piazzi
99 honest don't know if I should be
asking this but are you Andy Blaine
still together no Blaine and I broke up
in September last year I think he
mentioned it publicly in February but we
didn't announce when we were dating so
it didn't seem like we should announce
when we broke up
we discussed the idea of doing that but
it just seems like such a weird thing to
do to tell strangers the status of your
relationship
what still friends we talk all the time
we got pizza last weekend in Austin at
our favorite pizza place hum slice pizza
I love you
Marky Mark 95 said if there's one thing
that you would change about yourself
what would it be and why PS love you in
fawn house thank you uh I have just a
lot of things wrong with me
illnesses that I would just get rid of
there are so many things wrong with me
it is absurd muga underscore said what
is your favorite memory with funhouse so
far I mean the hottest I can remember
laughing in recent memory is at Adams
mega Fox chew during our drunk smash
dream I'm going to show you the clip of
that if you haven't seen it
[Music]
[Laughter]
who was this all just ocg us that I saw
a recent post you did stand-up comedy
for the first time how did you get into
something like that where can I start to
do the same thing so I did stand-up
comedy at RTX as part of the kind of
funny comedy night so it was very easy
for me to do because it was organized
through people I know and I actually
reached out to them and asked if I could
do it doing stand-up comedy has been a
goal of mine for probably like five
years I told the friend back in
Australia I was like if I don't do
stand-up within the next five years get
mad at me because it's something that I
want to try doing and it just worked out
perfectly that I had friends who were
having a comedy night but of course you
can do open mics at any point a few
people asked me about my procedure for
how I approached it I poached it as I do
with anything alive that I ever do which
is kind of with as little preparation as
possible because I feel like for some
reason that makes me more comfortable so
I knew the story that I was going to
tell and I did write it out maybe an
hour before we went live though through
the week I had been like you know sort
of in my head every now and then
thinking about what I was going to say
then I wrote a full thing out and then
I'm just trying to remember the beats
but I did make a lot of jokes on the fly
and I had a lot of fun doing it hammer
just told me that my memory card was
faults if the camera angle looks
dramatically different all of a sudden
you know why what was I talking about
kind of funny comedy night I believe
kind of funny recorded all of our sets
people have been asking me when it goes
up but I don't own that footage it was
their night
yeah I'll tweet and share and Instagram
and all that stuff when kind of funny
posted if they do Chevy 75 said I really
miss hearing you want Xbox unlocked are
you doing any guest appearances anytime
soon I almost did at e3 but I had a
scheduling conflict they asked to me
when I was actually moderating the
control panel for REME games
I'd love to guest I'd do it anytime that
I could but I think they record midweek
and obviously I work full time so that
doesn't really work out when they are in
a different City
Houston 94 said how bad to bruce's
fought smell surprisingly not that bad
they're very noisy and he does this
thing that I love why he just owns it
he'll fought really loudly and then be
like don't worry about that I've never
smelt one though I hear I hear they are
bad
I just haven't experienced it Jay as
sherry said who do you go for in the
state of origin my state of origin
Queensland I was born in Cannes raised
in Brisbane Marsh man 48 said what was
the major factor that had you come to
the US a penny for four years now almost
five the video game industry that's it
Pink Floyd 95 said favorite Liverpool FC
player
it is absolutely masala I adore him I
see him and I smile John Hogan 23 said
how many months do you think until
half-life 3 drops no drug that game is
in development like this is the thing
that I can't even really leet because
nobody would ever believe me but it is
in its vo ok good day can't be 94 us if
you could do the same job enrolling you
do now would you rather be based in the
US or Australia listen I prefer living
in Australia to the u.s. dramatically I
miss my family like crazy all day every
day pretty much but I was said before
the industry I work in is in the u.s. if
I want to progress in my career which I
do I'm a very ambitious person and I
would like that career to stay in the
games industry I need to be in the
United States pretty much I can see
myself going on hiatus and like pausing
that advancement for a while and going
to Europe but as far as the games
industry in Australia is concerned that
isn't enough there for me and for the
ambitions that I had corner Street he
said how did you feel after that 24
hours stream yeah we did a 24 hour
stream at fun towns to raise money for
charity it was bad I had a really bad
headache I vomited I slept like a rock
and then two three days afterwards I was
pretty bad so you know we appreciate
that you watched and helps donate thank
you an interesting name on Instagram
said what's your favorite gaming memory
I have a lot of favorites but a recent
one I can very easily pull to pull from
was that sense when breath of the wild
came out we got it a little bit early at
IGN and I was one of the people who was
playing it early along with Jose Otero
and Brendan and we would like pool each
other in a meeting rooms to talk about
things we had found
one of my favorite nights I think it was
the three of us but mostly Hosea and I I
was playing handheld and he was playing
on a projector in a room and I Jane that
is basically blacked out he was a lot
further ahead in the game than me
because he was reviewing it and
occasionally he would like tell me to
leave the room because he knew his story
meat was coming and then I would come
back in and it was just like hanging out
there until five or six a.m. on a work
night you know having to be back at work
at 10:00 a.m. and just being so excited
about everything we found that week
before Zelda launched was magical
Steve's amis e15 and frankly a lot of
other people asked will read lips orange
come back for anyone who don't know that
is my podcast I've been waiting on
something for a very long time to be
able to tell you that the thing I'm
waiting on I'm no longer waiting on and
I am now waiting on something else
the plan is yes that is the plan Nick
James 2-1-1 to us what's up with the
nepotism a true Steve and its sister
groups I can easily answer this question
roosterteeth functions as a company that
almost markets friendships and I think a
big part of that is that when they test
you on camera you have to fit in like
you're a friend like you've always been
a friend because that's the whole brand
if someone doesn't fit in doesn't
immediately feel like a part of a friend
group it's probably not gonna work
because of that because roosterteeth
content is about friendships and people
being friends and making fun of each
other in friendly ways I think that
leads to them hiring a lot of people who
are friends with one another or dating
one another or whatever else I can't
actually speak to that because I'm not
in hiring at roosterteeth but that would
be my guess
but of course they have also had plenty
of people who haven't known anyone so
that's not a consistent thing rich
mythos said what do you think is gonna
get game of the year listen I'm
generally pretty good at guessing this I
was right lost she I was right before
that my personal game of the year is
usually different to what I guess most
outlets will give Game of the Year right
now mine are sick row and Resident Evil
I actually think doom eternal might get
game of the year this year unless
something like lost of his part to ends
up coming out this year but I did play
Doom eternal at e3 and it [ __ ] rules
seriously life like said I have a
question what's your favorite thing
about yourself I'm totally fine with my
own company and very independent
I don't need other people to be happy
and I think that that is something that
I should not take for granted because I
know a lot of other people struggle with
that you can pretty much be by myself
for a week and find a million things to
do and be happy
Dean sawsan said how often does the
office at fun house actually feel like
work and how often does it feel like
playing with your friends funnily enough
the fun house office is actually
extremely quiet aside from one more on
camera because everyone kind of you know
has the energy for that and expels their
energy there it's super quiet alien boy
said can you cook pasta define cook I
could chuck some [ __ ] in a pot and boil
it Agora Hmong said what is a guilty
pleasure game that you play but try not
to let people know [ __ ] I do not care
there is nothing that I hide from people
when it comes to that kind of thing like
I play a ton of Pokemon go which you
could argue was a crappy casual game I
tweet about that shade I post about that
[ __ ] I do not care if people know Cathal
Walsh one two three said where can I
check out your music slash DJing people
ask me this so often even though it
seems like I post about it all the time
I have a soundcloud and I do also have a
YouTube channel that has music on it but
I've never promoted that I thought I
would just let it be a thing that people
just find if they search for it I've
never shared it anywhere SoundCloud is
soundcloud.com slashed our alums odd and
be 87 said where do you see yourself in
five or ten years I see myself working
in the industry side of video games I
see myself working for a studio on a
video game I think I want to be a
narrative designer probably start as a
writer that's the plan it's loose and
vague but that's where I think I'm
headed bobbin edward said chuck
questions sushi or pizza that depends on
the mood I love both of those things
depends what mood I'm in serious
question any plans on getting back into
streaming or streaming regularly I've
never streamed regularly i think i've
streamed like 5 times in total ever 6
maybe I did stream less than a month ago
I think there's real record for me but I
would like to do it more regularly that
would be cool I'll see if I can figure
it out ideally I would get to a point
where I'm doing it once a week but I
don't know not as though we have time
for I need to fly to San Diego so sorry
if there are like weird lines on this
video just because the it's a camera
thing it's not that interesting to
explain so I won't but seriously thank
you guys so much for 260,000
Scribus now that's amazing thank you for
watching the room to a video that was a
long time coming I know I promised it
forever ago glad I finally got around to
making it but that is it for me today
everyone I'm on and I will see you guys
next time